اليوم خلال مؤتمر صحفي لوزير الخارجيه
العراقي فؤاد حسين من مقر الوزاره في
بغداد قطع الوزير المؤتمر الصحفي فجاه
العماله العراقيه ما هي اليه سداد الدين
وروسيه على العراق وهل يمكن اتخاذ اسلوب
الاستداد كما حدثت
مع ايران
هذه المناقشات كانت جزءا من المناقشات
بيننا وبين السيد سري لافروف وزير خارجيه
روسيا الاتحاديه حينما زار
بغداد
حينما زار بغداد
مثل ما شفنا الوزير كان واضح عليه التعب
والاعياء وحاول يشرب الماء وانه يتمالك
نفسه لكن يبدو انه الوعكه الصحيه كانت
اقوى فغادر معتذرا عموما وسائل اعلام
عراقيه رجعت لاحقا نشرت مقطع قالت انه
للوزير وهو بيغادر وهو بصحه جيده ومبتسم
وسط الصحفيين اللي كانوا بيهنوا بالسلام
الحمد لله على السلامه
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]